es geht um sophia thomalla und die ist
mit keinem geringeren zusammen als mit
tennis olympiasieger alexander zverev
alles zu diesem neuen überraschenden
paar hat jetzt unsere show
chef-ingenieur kirsch hier bei uns im
studio herzlich willkommen guten morgen
unfassbar die beiden sind zusammen wie
sie sich kennengelernt ich kann das auch
noch gar nicht so richtig glauben ich
weiß gar nicht wer hier den das ist der
liebes aufschlag des jahres sozusagen
also 1 8 für beide die beiden haben sich
kennengelernt für ein paar jahren
ungefähr vor vier jahren über einen
gemeinsamen freund
und so vor sechs wochen ungefähr ist das
denn alles so in gang gekommen da sind
quasi die ja funken übergesprungen
in einem zeitalter von social media
instagram und co kann man es ja auch
recht einfach da so ein bisschen kontakt
zu halten oder wieder in kontakt zu
treten tatsächlich war sie ja auch im
september bei schlag den star da ist
zwar gegen eine fette angetreten also
der ex von mama simone und wir dachten
alle damals auch das aber nett von sofia
dass sie damit extra hin fährt um ein
bisschen händchen zu halten und den
silvio zu trösten jetzt wissen wir auch
warum sie wirklich da war jetzt würde
ich sagen das passt ja wunderbar in
diese welt das sind tolle fotos das
hilft der 1
das hilft dem anderen sagt ganz ehrlich
janina was glaubst du wie ernst die
ganze geschichte ist
also überrascht hat mich das ganze schon
weil ich die verbindung vorher nicht
kannte aber eigentlich sollte ein bei
sophia thomalla gar nichts mehr
überraschen weil es hat nie so lange
gedauert bis sie neuen freund hatte
ich glaube schon dass es nicht nur ein
flirt ist ich bin mir sicher dass es
nicht nur ein flirt ist denn sie ist
letzte woche nach florida geflogen da
spielt er ja gerade tennis in wales und
hat ihn besucht ist dann jetzt wieder
zurück gekommen um hier ihren geburtstag
zu feiern ihren 32 ich würde nicht um
den halben globus fliegen nur für einen
kleinen flirt und spielt richtig gut
geworden er ist also könnte hinweis
darauf sein dass ist flott man dachte ja
der olympiasieg hat ihn beflügelt
vielleicht ist es auch einfach die liebe
die ihn jetzt beflügelt interessant ist
dass er angesprochen wurde bei der
pressekonferenz jetzt und gefragt oder
wir denn sophia thomalla findet und dann
hat er gesagt sie ist ganz nett und
grinste dann ganz schnell wird also ich
sag ja immer nett ist die kleine
schwester von scheiße aber ich glaube er
hat so anders gemeint wäre so gewesen
wir sind nur freunde ist auch die
eindeutige aussage darüber wie nah sie
ist ganz nett mit zum
süffisanten grinsen im gesicht dass da
brauchen nicht mehr viel sagen jetzt
müssen wir einmal das liebesleben der
beiden ein bisschen auseinander
sortieren denn sophia frisch getrennt
und wie sieht's bei alexander zverev
überhaupt euch der zverev ist seit
letztem jahr getrennt er hat ja war mit
einem jet gntm model zusammen die beiden
haben auch ein gemeinsames kind eine
tochter sind aber mittlerweile getrennt
und ja er hatte ein bisschen länger zeit
um das single leben zu genießen als sie
und sie ja im juni erst die trennung der
wir erinnern uns alle an diese fotos von
loris karius der ja damals noch mit
sophia zusammen wir auf einer yacht von
mykonos mit einem argentinischen
bikini model geflirtet hat da waren wir
alle ein bisschen sprachlos dass der
loris sich das getraut hat damals
genauso wie sie die sophia die im jahr
als sie die bilder gesehen hat sofort
den laufpass dieser sei jetzt das model
das ist das einzig maria maria del mar
ist er auch so ein wunderschöner sexy
name und da konnte er nicht so richtig
die finger von männern wirklich so ist
oder künstler
doch maría del mar musa
also das geht auf der zunge der name und
ihm ging es wohl nicht anders aber als
sophia damals die bilder gesehen hat hat
sie ihm sofort den laufpass gegeben und
hat dann auch zu uns gesagt wir gehen
jetzt getrennte wege wir sind getrennte
leute also da war sie schon ein bisschen
sauer man hört aber aus dem umfeld der
beiden jetzt dass die sich echt also
sofia und zverev wahnsinnig gut
verstehen sollen sie beliebt sein humor
hat ein freund zu uns gesagt sind nur
den humor lebt oder auch mehr sich
wahnsinnig gut verstehen es immer super
wenn man zusammen ist das passt einfach
gut janina noch zwei abschließenden
fragen vielleicht der auftrag zur
recherche hat alex wäre schon ein sofia
tattoo und sophia thomalla tennis also
die frage müsste eigentlich lauten hat
sophia schon ein 28 oder soja wenn sie
ist ja diejenigen die so viele tattoos
hat und die auch immer symbole hat als
sie hat zum beispiel es gibt ein tattoo
was sie an sven martinek erinnert der ja
einer ihrer ziehväter war dann till
lindemann ihr ex ich will noch aber eine
sache sagen man denkt vielleicht das ist
eine total komische kombination weil er
ja auch schon kind hat und sie
eigentlich man vielleicht nicht denkt
dass sie so ein krasser familienmensch
ist das ist aber klar dass wir sind
total patchwork abrupt sie hat alle
männer von mama simone immer akzeptiert
sven martinek rudi assauer silvio
heinevetter hatte ein wahnsinnig enges
verhältnis zu den und selber hat sie ja
auch mal geben rossdale gedatet den ex
von gwen stefani der ja auch vier kinder
hat und da gab es damit sieht es schön
fotos wie sie in amerika ist und eines
der kinder auf dem arm trägt also es ist
nicht so dass sophia kein familienmensch
ist ganz im gegenteil total dies super
patchwork abrupt deswegen kann ich mir
auch vorstellen dass das gut passen
würde also großes tennis in sachen wie
wir nach so und ob ihr tennisspiel keine
ahnung keine ahnung
dazu wird juliane und beantworte euch
das beim nächsten mal sportlich ist ja
auf jeden fall insofern wird sie auch
ein schläger halten können
[Musik]